well if chemists speaking body language
since she's a mother dictionary you
don't know Kanye West is clearly wife
Kim Kardashian's hype man we love each
other's opinions it's extremely
important to me in a rare interview for
e true Hollywood story who is Kim
kardashian-west
the 42 year old rapper sweetly opens up
about the mother of his four children
and et's taking a look at the best
moments from easy this is my wife this
is my life it's safe to say him broke
the mold when it comes to stardom and
easy agrees she's one powerful woman Kim
does have all of this potential we just
began to untap the amount of potential
of power that she has going for it
and having no fear yeh doesn't like
bringing up negative memories from their
past especially the Paris robbery that
left his wife forever changed there are
a lot of thoughts running through my
head related to that time and I don't
like to watch those movies memories or
movies in your mind I like to watch the
happy ones I don't search for the bad he
reveals what about Kim made him fall in
love and why their connection was
undeniable any time I was around her I
saw her it was a magnetic attraction to
this force of energy she was good
pure happy loving brave courageous
strong I think that's just a really good
foundation for a good relationship so I
think that in life what I've learned is
you just kind of have to go with it and
be happy and right now I'm just living
in the moment of being happy but above
all Kanye sweetly admits he couldn't be
more proud of the k'kaw Beauty mogul
whether she's getting someone out of
prison but she's posting a photo when
her nipples barely covered this is who I
married and that's what we love that's
what makes this game called life
exciting he's just the most genuine
person
[Music]
[Applause]